sarah's in pensacola hi sarah how are
you hi
thank you so much for having me sure
what's up
so i just finished my first semester of
grad school yesterday
and i was a resident assistant on campus
but my contract ends in about a week so
after that i'm moving back home to
continue school online
i have another job but i make five or
less hours a week and it only pays 11 an
hour
and i'd really like to set myself up in
my career to be financially stable so
i'm wondering
should i hold off on baby step four to
make sure i can pay for school yes
yes okay and then how can i make sure
that i i actually set myself up
financially
to go through this because i'm clearly
not making enough money
to come up yeah you obviously need to
work more yeah five hours a week
yeah it says it's supposed to be 10 to
15 but it's a remote position and the
work that i'm actually getting is not
much
but i don't really know whether i should
look for like an internship
or another route what are you doing now
so i just received my bachelor's degree
in communications last semester
and my um program now is in strategic
communication and leadership
i mean i mean for work what are you
doing for work that five hours
for work i currently work as a student
assistant for
um the center for cyber security at my
school okay
but i'm doing like community and public
relations kind of work so it is
in my field but it's not really exactly
what i'm trying to do i really want to
like
get a salary based kind of job and
make sure i can cash flow my college
basically
yeah i mean you need to get your income
up your hour's up and your pay up
and it doesn't matter if it's in the
field of what you want to do you just
need the money right now to pay for
school if you're doing
it online what would keep you from just
going and getting a job
that is in your field as if you just
graduated from college
because you did and take that income
and use that to pay for your online and
work a full-time job you don't need an
internship
so do i need to focus on finding a job
in my field first because i don't want a
bachelor's degree
that'd be wonderful okay that'd be great
but if you can you know
then just get something no i i think i
would and i think i would
you know here here's here's your a plus
okay a job that's 40 or
hours a week or more and you do your
online nights and weekends
and you finish up your your masters or
whatever it is you're working on your
grad work there
that way oh and by the way this new job
not only is in your field but they have
a tuition reimbursement program and they
pay for it
wow i'm just getting a lot of home runs
here this is going to be awesome
but uh yeah you're still trying to act
like a college student i think you just
go ahead and be the adult stuff
yeah i'm only 19 in you know grad school
so i'm kind of like
still trying to save money and figure
out so you blew through the four years
real fast huh i definitely did yeah
okay what am i doing now she's like i'm
acting 19 because i am 19 dave
give me one in the world what do you uh
what is it you're wanting to do when you
when when you're 30 what do you want to
be doing
if i'm being completely honest i started
thinking about this a little bit more
now that i started listening to your
show but i would love to be an author
one day
okay what do you want to do as a career
path
between now and then so i was looking
into that and some jobs that i was
looking to applying for
were actually content marketing
specialists yeah um not exactly
communications but
oh no it is communications all the
journalism students are filling up my
content room down here
i got tons of content folks on our team
that are writing in our voices and
helping us get
stuff out of here because we're putting
out so much product out of here every
day
and content specialists yes you're
totally qualified for that
oh and by the way you're under 40 which
means you can use a computer
yeah definitely but yeah that's that's
that was age discrimination
as a joke she's like well of course i
can date of course what a weird
statement
i have better keyboard skills with my
thumbs than you do dave but yeah
the uh uh so yeah that's that's that's
what yeah
yes go get a job as a content marketing
specialist with a company
that will pay for you to finish your
master's and that is a great springboard
into becoming an author 10 years from
today
okay awesome i just wanted to make sure
i'm still on the right path with that
yeah cause you're gonna you're gonna
write you're gonna write
you know what writers should do writers
should write yeah
i started a blog and i'm like i kind of
want to continue that too on the side
yeah absolutely that's a good place to
practice and do all kinds of stuff but
there's not much money in that probably
right now
but yeah i mean you get a job as a
content marketing specialist making 50k
and they i have a tuition reimbursement
benefit and you're working 40 hours and
you're doing your own line to finish up
your grad work
and you're and you're pumping out
keyboard material all day long that is
actually relevant in the marketplace
you're starting to learn how to do stuff
that's awesome
and just flexing that muscle it's
amazing how on the other side of this on
the other side of your grad school
graduation
your writing muscles will be so much
stronger because you spent time writing
not just in the classroom not just for
homework but in real world scenarios and
on your blog
all of that's going to strengthen you as
a writer sir let me tell you what's
underlying both of our answers on this
we're both looking at you going you
think your master's degree is your
secret sauce
we are talking to an incredible rock
star 19 year old
we think you are the secret sauce and i
think you've been putting the weight on
the wrong
sauce you is the answer kid
get it get it you know how to do it you
went ahead and got you so goal freaking
oriented she got a four-year degree at
19 years old
get it get it i mean that's it man it's
until you asked her age it was like you
were saying she's seeing herself as a
grad student and she seen herself
and i'm like no no you are a college
graduate at 19 by the way
that has a degree should go get a job
and oh by the way
is taking grad school classes that's the
afterthought
not the money and work piece of it and
man that's going to set you up so well
moms and dads teach your kids that
education is important but that
is not the secret sauce that the person
in the mirror is their secret sauce
no one cares about your degree or where
it came from they care can you do stuff
out here in the real world and you have
to be able to look at me
and articulately as the potential
employer
articulately describe that you can do
crap
and when you can do that i don't really
care
uh you know where you went to school i
don't care
what you're whatever you are i don't
care man woman black white pink purple i
don't care what you are
we have a lot of pink people that work
we do we've got a few look like they
fell in a tackle box but it's it's good
you know they're beautiful and they they
they they can do stuff man and that's
all i care about i know i mean that's
we love them it's all i care about
they're creative and they get stuff done
and so
that's what moms and dads you teach your
kids
look take their little face in your
hands you're the secret sauce
and yes you need to know stuff and get
you know get the degree
do the academic work but then don't lean
back and go well i've got a degree and
nobody gives a crap the other thing that
sarah's going to learn when she starts
writing is whether or not she wants to
keep writing
yeah because she may start writing and
realize i hate this i don't want to do
this i want to do a different path with
my skill set with my degree
dave do you know my degree is in
advertising i'm not using i'm not
working in advertising agency but i use
that education every day and what i do
teaching women through business boutique
with marketing
even on our team strategizing how we're
going to market and advertise stuff
but it doesn't have to be this perfect
linear path
of using your degree exactly like you
think you're going to you're going to
learn a lot about yourself sarah in
these next few years
through doing some stuff of what you
want to do more of
and it's going to pull from your
education but maybe not exactly like you
think it will
yeah and by the way ladies and gentlemen
we can't keep christy from writing it's
impossible to stop her from writing
keep her away from the keyboard she's
doing it again dave when can i write my
next book he's like you haven't even
released this book
and would you please make it thinner you
got lots of words
i do you got lots of words i do it's
wonderful
[Laughter]
and uh and i'm in the middle of a
writing project and it's
i'm quite the opposite i got lots of
words but they're not on paper i have to
put them on paper now rachel says every
time she writes a book she says i can't
believe you like this
yeah i feel like i'm right i have a term
paper due but uh
but yeah it's good i i enjoy what books
do but putting them together so
there's a beautiful thing happening here
y'all that um
there's something you take away from
that last call and that is is that
um we do not want to say
education is not important in america
just because there's an epic student
loan crisis
and fools have gotten degrees in
left-handed puppetry and feel entitled
that is not an education crisis that is
a wisdom
crisis and so wisdom says
knowledge is important but it is not
the thing it is part of the thing
the thing is you
you get up leave the cave kill something
drag it home